[Music]
this farmer's truck is covered in rocks
hay and sand
here's how reese from satisfying clean
details filthy vehicles to look brand
new
the first step is to clear any garbage
in the interior
reese removes hay by hand because it's
faster than using a vacuum
next he removes the floor mats so he can
access all the sand and dirt underneath
[Music]
greece starts from the top of the
vehicle first so that all the sand falls
to the floor this is the best way to
avoid double cleaning
[Music]
a special wet and dry detailing vacuum
is used to remove dirt sand and debris
vacuuming the floors takes the longest
but has the biggest payoff
it's important to vacuum those hard to
reach areas to try to get as much dirt
and sand out of the interior as possible
before moving on to the next step
after dry vacuuming reese sprays an
all-purpose cleaner on the petals and
uses a fingernail brush to scrub off the
dirt
next the floor and carpets are sprayed
[Music]
reese uses a drill brush to agitate the
floor
this releases the dirt so that it can be
easily vacuumed up
[Music]
it's important to always spray the
interior first so that the drill brush
doesn't damage any surfaces
[Music]
to finish cleaning the floors the
remainder of the dirt is vacuumed up
this process is repeated throughout the
vehicle on different surfaces
[Music]
for smaller areas a detailing brush is
used to remove dirt
to finish the process
reese sprays a polish on all the
interior plastics and wipes it away to
reveal a bright shiny finish
[Music]
the process can take anywhere from two
to four hours but farmers are always
pleased with the transformation
[Music]
you